the octopus a type of cephalopod is a
fascinating creature
it has three hearts and eight arms those
arms also contain most of its brain with
500 million nerve cells and real
superpowers
octopuses are highly intelligent
depending on their environment they can
change their shape color pattern and
even the texture of their skin
[Music]
they can turn into rocks looking like
they're covered in algae
or make themselves huge and turn
completely red
muy extendidos
at an unam university satellite campus
in the mexican coastal town of seesaw
biologist carlos rosas is researching
the octopus's ideal living conditions
results so far the sensitive animal
reacts dramatically to rising water
temperatures by laying fewer eggs
this could become a problem if climate
change progresses
we know today that the caribbean sea and
the gulf of mexico are warming because
of climate change
we want to create models that can
predict whether the number of octopuses
will decrease in the future
there are still plenty of them here
along the coast of the yucatan but that
could change
demand for the low-fat delicacy is
rising worldwide and in some asian
regions they've already been overfished
for octopus catcher antonio coque in
cecil business is better than ever this
season
it's been insane especially august and
september and into october it always
depends on how long you want to work i'm
usually full by 1 pm and i earn around
500 600 pesos the people who stay out
all afternoon make 2 000 or 3 000 pesos
but antonio cox is also worried about
whether extensive fishing can go on
forever
that's why he's working with the
university's scientists to sell octopus
raised in a breeding station instead of
capturing them out at sea
farming octopus is one of the biggest
challenges facing the global seafood
industry
unlike salmon and shrimp they're
sensitive to captivity and die quickly
but the mexican researchers have one
advantage the local species the maya is
particularly robust
this one is already two months old
the maya octopus is a very pleasant
species
and besides they don't emerge from the
eggs the females hatch as larvae but has
fully developed tiny octopuses
other octopus species are born as pera
larvae at that stage of development
massive numbers of them tend to die
here in sisol where the hatchlings skip
the larval stage they breed surprisingly
well
the heart of the university station
soon new little maya octopuses will
emerge from these eggs
if you look closely you can see small
black dots the tiny eyes of the baby
creatures and new eggs are already on
the way again
we have 32 tangs here and in each one
there's a pregnant female now we're
waiting for them to lay their eggs
the scientists capture the pregnant
females in the open sea they're just one
year old and die after laying their eggs
they starve themselves to death here in
the breeding station as in the wild
but keeping octopuses in captivity even
if only at the end of their lives is
always a source of controversy the
animals are so intelligent that critics
consider it morally wrong to confine
them
carlos rosas sees things differently
we've anthropomorphized the octopus
through movies and other stories that
are spread
and that's a problem
in southern mexico the octopus is
regarded as a resource it's a source of
income and food for many people in the
village
in a moment you'll see how delicious
this is
the [ __ ] family is having it for lunch
today
here in yucatan you'll be offered
octopus everywhere you go
also in restaurants
sylvia [ __ ] serves fried octopus with
her escape sauce
in other mexican regions octopus is
served in sushi a popular dish in mexico
the world's appetite is huge some
420 000 tons of octopus are eaten
annually
antonio and sylvia koch come to the unam
university research facility every day
and volunteer to help raise the
octopuses
they're learning how to successfully
breed and raise them in this artificial
environment
1.6 grams
the very small ones get stressed out
very quickly
while the scientists focus on their
research and collect data antonio [ __ ]
and his wife have now founded the
molosko stell miab cooperative to expand
octopus farming commercially the other
catchers in the village were not very
enthusiastic about the project at first
he used this they said it was crazy just
a waste of time
they didn't believe in the project
now almost 10 octopus catchers are
organized within the cooperative with
the help of support funding they were
recently able to finance their own site
the tanks are already in place but they
still need money to get things up and
running
we want to expand our project so that we
can increase our market selling
nationally and internationally that's my
dream preferably starting tomorrow
this project could secure the future for
many fishing families and perhaps become
a model for other regions affected by
overfishing and climate change
[Music]
you